SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO, GIL ARCHULETA,
ASHBY, ATKINS, BECKER,
BLAKESPEAR, BRADFORD CABALLERO,
CORTEZ DALI, DAR DURAZO, EGM
GLAZER, GONZALEZ GROVE, HURTADO
JONES, LAIRD, LIMÓN MCGUIRE,
MENJIVAR MIN. NEW MIN WEN NILO,
OCHO PADILLA, PORTANTINO ROTH
RUBIO SEYARTO SKINNER. SMALL
WORK CUE STERN HAMBURG, WAHAB
WIENER WILK. MEMBERS. A QUORUM
IS PRESENT. WHAT THE MEMBERS AND
OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL AND
IN THE GALLERY, PLEASE RISE.
WILL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
AFTERNOON BY OUR CHAPLAIN,
SISTER MICHELLE GORMAN. AFTER
WHICH WE'RE GONNA ASK YOU TO
REMAIN STANDING FOR THE PLEDGE
OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. WE
GATHER IN GOD'S PRESENCE. AND WE
PRAY TODAY, IN THE WORDS OF EE.
CUMMINGS. I THANK YOU. GOD FOR
MOST THIS AMAZING DAY. FOR THE
LEAPING GREENLEAF SPIRITS OF
TREES. AND A BLUE TRUE DREAM OF
SKY. AND FOR EVERYTHING, WHICH
IS NATURAL. WHICH IS INFINITE,
WHICH IS YES. I WHO HAVE DIED AM
ALIVE AGAIN TODAY. THIS IS THE
SON'S BIRTHDAY. THIS IS THE
BIRTHDAY OF LIFE AND OF LOVE AND
WINGS. AND OF THE GÂY GREAT
HAPPENING ILLIMITABLE EARTH. HOW
SHOULD TASTING TOUCHING HEARING
SEEING BREATHING? ANY HUMAN
MERELY BEING DOUBT UNIMAGINABLE.
YOU NOW THE EARS OF MY EARS
AWAKE. AND NOW THE EYES OF MY
EYES ARE OPENED. AMEN. MEMBERS
JOIN ME IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE.
NÓ.
MEMBERS WELCOME BACK FROM OUR
SPRING RECESS. WE'RE QUICKLY
MOVING THROUGH THE AGENDA. WE'RE
FIRST UP IS PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR. I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO WISH A HAPPY
BELATED BIRTHDAY TO SENATOR
LAIRD. CELEBRATED A BIRTHDAY
LAST FRIDAY. HAPPY BIRTHDAY. AND
ALSO ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
ARCHULETA. PLEASE WELCOME DOCTOR
ZOLA, Dð ESCOBAR. HEALTH CARE
LEADER, PHILANTHROPIST,
PRESIDENT AND CHIEF
ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICER OF AL
DOCTOR ESCOBAR IS A SENATOR.
SELECTION OF WOMEN OF THE YEAR.
PLEASE GIVE HER A WARM SENATE.
WELCOME. NOW, MEMBERS MOVING ON
THE MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
WILL BE DEEMED RED. MESSAGES
FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED
READ. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. NOW MOVING ON TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION. THE SENATE JOURNALS
FOR MARCH 18TH 2024 THROUGH
MARCH, 21 2024 WILL BE APPROVED
AS CORRECTED BY THE MINUTE
CLERK. NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
UNDER GOVERNOR APPOINTMENTS. WE
HAVE TWO SENATOR LÀ PREPARED
SENATOR LAIRD WHEN YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MR
PRESIDENT. FINAL ITEM NUMBER ONE
IS THE CONFIRMATION OF THE
FOLLOWING FOUR APPOINTMENTS TO
THE COMMISSION ON THE STATUS OF
WOMEN AND GIRLS. UH CASA AMINI,
ERICA, COURTNEY, RITA GALLARDO
GOOD AND CRYSTAL YOUNG. THEY ALL
BRING UNIQUE BACKGROUNDS TO THE
COMMISSION. UH, MS AMI IS AN
INTERNATIONAL HUMAN RIGHTS
ADVOCATE. MS COURTNEY IS IN THE
U S¼ ARMY RESERVE AND A MEMBER
OF THE JOINT CHIEFS OF STAFF FOR
THE U S¼ DEPARTMENT OF THE STAFF
. MS GARDO IS THE DIRECTOR OF
CIVIC AFFAIRS AT CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY, SACRAMENTO,
AND MS YOUNG IS A COMMUNICATIONS
PROFESSIONAL SERVING IN THE
OFFICE OF THE FIRST PARTNER. ALL
FOUR MEMBERS WHO WERE APPROVED
BY THE RULES COMMITTEE ON MARCH
6TH. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I
VÆ THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
APPOINTMENT? ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE HEARING. SEE NONE.
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HØI I BROUGHT GIL
ARCHULETA. HØI ASHBY, HØI
ATKINS, HØI BECKER. AYE,
BLAKESPEAR. AYE, BRADFORD. HØI
CABALLERO. AYE, CORTESI. HØI
DALLY. DODD. HØI DURAZO. HØI
EDMUND. HIY GLAZER. HØI
GONZALEZ, A GROVE? HURTADO.
JONES. LAIRD. HØI HØI MCGUIRE.
HØI MENJIVAR. AYE, MEN. HØI
NEWMAN A WIN. NILO. BUT PA.
PORTANTINO AYE, ROTH. AYE RUBIO
IY SEYARTO. DINNER. AYE, SMALLER
CUEVAS. UH, HUMBERG. AYE, W. HIY
WEINER. AYE. WELL, PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALVARADO
GIL. HØI DALLY. GROVE. HURTADO.
JONES. WHEN NILO. OR TO B. HØI
SEYARTO SMALLER CUEVAS. I
WELCOME. I 32 KNOWS ZERO. THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED. NOW
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM TWO.
SENATOR LÀ. THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT. FINAL ITEM NUMBER TWO
IS THE CONFIRMATION OF JEFFREY
WILLIAMS AS A MEMBER OF THE
STATE PARK AND RECREATION
COMMISSION SINCE 2017 HE'S BEEN
VICE PRESIDENT OF PRODUCTION FOR
THE BLACK ENTERTAINMENT
TELEVISION MEDIA GROUP. HE IS
ALSO THE FOUNDER AND CO
PRESIDENT OF THE BLACK SURFERS
COLLECTIVE. UH, HE WAS APPROVED
BY THE RULES COMMITTEE ON MARCH
6TH. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
EYE VOTE. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
APPOINTMENT? YOU DIDN'T SEE
NONE. SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. HØI. AYE, A GIL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE, ASHBY. AYE,
ATKINS. AYE, BECKER. AYE,
BLAKESPEAR. HØI BRADFORD. AYE,
CABALLERO. ALL RIGHT, CORTESE.
AYE, DALLY. NÓ DAD. AYE, DURAZO.
HIY EGM. AYE, GLASER. AY
GONZALEZ AYE, GROVE. NÓ HURTADO.
JONES. LAIRD. AYE, LIMÓN.
MAGUIRE. HØI MAJAR. AYE MIN. HØI
NEWMAN. AYE. WHEN NÓ NILO. NÓ A
TRIAL. NÓ PAD. AY PORTANTINO
AYE, ROTH. AYE, RUBIO. I SEE NÓ
SKINNER. AY A SMALL I STERN. I
UMBER I WAHAB AYE, WIENER. AYE,
WILK. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBER. JONES. LEMON. AYE. WELL.
I 31 NOSE SIX. THE APPOINTMENT
IS CONFIRMED. NOW MEMBERS WERE
MOVING TO SENATE THIRD READING.
WE HAVE TWO ITEMS. FIRST UP IS
FOUL ITEM 17. MEMBER. ARE YOU
PREPARED? WERE SENATOR WAHAB,
YOU'RE PREPARED, SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ SEND A CURRENT
RESOLUTION 125 BY SENATOR WAHAB
RELATIVE TO RAMADAN. SENATOR
FLORES YOURS. THANK YOU.
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES I RISE
TO PRESENT S¼ èC R 125 RAMADAN.
RAMADAN IS THE HOLY MONTH OF
FASTING AND SPIRITUAL RENEWAL
WORLDWIDE. IS IT IS ONE OF THE
FIVE PILLARS OF ISLAM. IT IS A
TIME TO REFLECT SPIRITUALLY
BUILD COMMUNALLY. AID THOSE IN
NEED AND A CHANCE TO CELEBRATE
AND EXPRESS GRATITUDE. THE
MUSLIM HOLY MONTH OF RAMADAN
BEGAN AT DUSK ON SUNDAY, MARCH
10TH AND CONTINUES FOR ONE LUNAR
MONTH WITH MUSLIMS FASTING FROM
SUNRISE TO SUNSET EACH DAY.
FASTING IS MEANT TO BE A SHARED
COMMUNITY EXPERIENCE. NÓ ONE IS
REQUIRED TO FAST AND WE
ESPECIALLY ENSURE YOUNG CHILDREN
, THE ELDERLY, DISABLED
COMMUNITY MEMBERS, PREGNANT
WOMEN BREASTFEEDING, MOTHERS AND
TRAVELERS ARE SUPPORTED IN THEIR
DECISION NOT TO FAST. THE HUNGER
ENCOURAGES US TO CONSIDER OUR
VALUES AND NECESSITIES AND HOW
OUR LIVES DO OR DO NOT ALIGN
WITH WHAT IS IMPORTANT TO US.
BREAKING THE FAST WITH FRIENDS
AND FAMILY IN THEIR EARLY HOURS
OF THE MORNING AND LATE IN THE
EVENING REMINDS US OF WHAT WE
SHOULD TREASURE AND ENJOY IN
LIFE. BUT FASTING HAS BEEN A
MENTAL AND EMOTIONAL CHALLENGE
FOR MANY MUSLIMS THIS YEAR.
ACROSS THE WORLD FAMINE WAR
DEATH HAVE TAKEN OVER INNOCENT
MEN, WOMEN AND CHILDREN HAVE
DIED. SURVIVOR'S GUILT IS REAL.
WHAT DOES IT MEAN TO CHOOSE TO
DENY ONESELF FOOD AS WE WITNESS
THE STARVATION OF MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE OF MULTIPLE FAITHS ACROSS
THE WORLD? SOME WITH NÓ ACCESS
TO BASIC CLEAN WATER. OR
SOMEWHERE TO USE THE RESTROOM.
WHILE MUSLIMS AROUND THE WORLD
ARE RESILIENT. THERE IS LESS JOY
THIS YEAR. IN MY OWN DISTRICT. I
HEAR THE PAIN AND SORROW OF
THOSE WHO HAVE LOST DOZENS OF
FAMILY MEMBERS IN GAZA. SOME
HAVE EVEN STATED THEIR ENTIRE
FAMILY HAS BEEN WIPED OUT. I'M
PROUD THAT ALL THE DIVERSITY
CAUCUSES, INCLUDING THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS AND JEWISH CAUCUS, SIGNED
ON TO A LETTER I WROTE IN
OCTOBER TO PRESIDENT BIDEN AND
SECRETARY BLINKEN. TO PRIORITIZE
HUMAN LIFE AND HUMANITARIAN AID.
THE LEAST WE CAN ASK FOR WE ALL
HAVE POWER TO DO MORE. SAFETY IS
THE FOUNDATION OF EVERY
COMMUNITY IN THE PATH TO PEACE.
THE WORK OF THE LEGISLATURE IS
TO BETTER THE LIVES OF THE
COMMUNITY. AND AS A MEMBER OF
THE WORLD. WE SHOULD ALL DO MORE
TO PROMOTE PEACE, LOVE AND
ACCEPTANCE. MANY IN THE
COMMUNITY HAVE DIRECTED THEIR
EMOTIONAL TURMOIL. INTO ONE OF
THE CORE TENANTS OF RAMADAN. AND
ZAKAT SPECIFICALLY IS GIVING TO
CHARITY IS ANOTHER PILLAR OF
ISLAM. THE UNITED NATIONS
REFUGEE AGENCY REPORTED RAISING
$46 MILLION IN RELATION TO
RAMADAN IN 2023. WE EXPECT ZAKAT
TO BE EVEN GREATER ACROSS THE
AGENCIES AND ORGANIZATIONS
SUPPORTING REFUGEES AND ASYLUM
SEEKERS. WE ARE SEEING REFUGEES
AND ASYLUM SEEKERS GROW EVERY
SINGLE DAY. I APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR. AND GOVERNOR NEWSOM,
ADDING HIS VOICE TO THE CALL FOR
A CEASEFIRE. BECAUSE IT IS WHAT
IS NEEDED. THE MOST RIGHT NOW.
AS RAMADAN CONTINUES TO A CLOSE
IN THE WHEAT NEXT WEEK OR THIS
WEEK. I SHOULD SAY I HOPE WE
FIND AN OPPORTUNITY TO
COLLABORATE ACROSS FAITHS TO
BUILD A LASTING PEACE. AT THE
END OF THE DAY. THE BEAUTY OF
THE UNITED STATES AND ESPECIALLY
IN CALIFORNIA. IS THAT WE CAN
CELEBRATE THE DIVERSITY OF EACH
OTHER. THE FACT THAT CESAR
CHÁVEZ DAY SAINT PATRICK'S DAY
NOW ROSE EASTER AND RAMADAN
WE'RE ALL CELEBRATED IN ONE
MONTH. SHOWS THE DIVERSITY OF
THIS GREAT NATION AND THE
ABILITY TO HONOR OUR DIFFERENCES
IN LOVE AND GRATITUDE. I HOPE WE
FIND AN OPPORTUNITY TO RENEW OUR
FAITH IN HUMANITY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I VOTE.
Q ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM? ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE HEARING YOU
SEEN AND SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALUN. AYE, ALVARADO,
GAIL. HIY ARCHULETA. AYE, ASHBY,
IY ATKINS. AYE, BECKER. AYE,
BLAKESPEAR. AYE, BRADFORD. AY
CABALLERO AY CORTESI AYE, DALLY.
AYE, TODD. TOO. AYE, GLASER.
AYE, GONZALEZ. HIY GROVE. I
JONES. LAIRD. HØI LEMON. AYE,
MCGUIRE. AY MANJAR AYE MIN. UH
NEW MEN I WEN AYE, NILO. I Ó
AYE, AYE, PORTANTINO. AYE, ROTH.
AYE, RUBIO. ALRIGHTY. SEYARTO,
UH SKINNER. AYE. SMALL WORK.
CUEVAS. I STERN. HØI AMBER. AYE.
WELL, HØI WEINER. I WILL. I 37
KNOW ZERO. THE RESOLUTION IS
APPROVED. NOW MEMBERS WERE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 19
SENATOR PINO, HE'S PREPARED
SECRETARY. YOU MAY READ SENATE A
RESOLUTION 76 BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO RELATIVE TO
INTERNATIONAL DARK SKY WEEK.
SOONER, PINO THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT S¼ èC R 76
COMMEMORATING APRIL 2ND THROUGH
THE EIGHTH AS INTERNATIONAL DARK
SKY WEEK IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA DARK NIGHT SKIES ARE
ESSENTIAL TO THE RHYTHMS OF
LIFE. LIGHT POLLUTION IS
DETRIMENTAL AND CAN NEGATIVELY
IMPACT HUMAN HEALTH,
CONTRIBUTING TO ENERGY WASTE AND
DISRUPT NATURAL DARKNESS ABOUT
80% OF THE WORLD'S POPULATION
EXISTS UNDER A BUBBLE OF LIGHT
POLLUTION. THEREFORE, THEY MAY
CEASE TO EXPERIENCE THE
ECOLOGICAL AND HEALTH BENEFITS
OF A DARK SKY. CALIFORNIA HOSTS
TWO INTERNATIONAL DARK SKY
COMMUNITIES BARGO SPRINGS AND
JULIAN AND THREE INTERNATIONAL
DARK SKY PARKS. DEATH VALLEY
JOSHUA TREE UH UH, ANZ BARGO
DESERT PARK WHICH ATTRACT STABLE
STREAMS OF INTERNATIONAL
TOURISTS. CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO
A MULTITUDE OF NOCTURNAL
WILDLIFE, INCLUDING MOUNTAIN
LIONS, BOBCATS, COYOTES,
RACCOONS, BATS, OWLS, MOTHS,
CRICKETS AND MANY MORE LIGHT
POLLUTION THREATENS, UH,
PREDATORS ABILITY. HUNT APPRAISE
ABILITY TO HIDE INTERRUPTS
MIGRATION PATTERNS PREVENTS
HUMANS FROM GETTING PROPER SLEEP
AND MANY MORE DETRIMENTAL
ACTIVITIES AMONGST YOUNG
CITIZENS. OUR FUTURE LEADERS, IT
IS CRITICAL THAT WE PRESERVE THE
FEELINGS OF WONDER AND AWE IN
ORDER TO PROMOTE THEIR GROWTH,
INTERESTS AND SCIENCE AND
INTEREST IN NATURE. I'D LIKE TO
THANK DARK SKY L, A COUNTY FOR
BRINGING THIS ISSUE TO MY
ATTENTION AND FOR ADVOCATING FOR
MORE DARK SKY PLACES AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM?
SECRETARY. YOU MAY CALL THE
ROLL, ALAN. AYE, IG. HIY
ARCHULETA, HIY ASHBY, IY ATKINS
ALL BECKER. AYE, BLAKESPEAR. UH,
BRADFORD. HØI CABALLERO. HIY
CORTEZ. HØI DALLY. DODD. AYE,
TOO. HØI EGM. AYE, GLASER.
GONZALEZ. A GROVE. HURTADO.
JONES. HØI AYE, MCGUIRE. IY
MANJAR. AYE, MEN. HØI NEWMAN IY.
WE NILO. A JOB. BY THE YEAR
PORTANTINO. HØI ROTH, HIY RUBIO.
AYE, SEYARTO. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALL CUEVAS. UH, STERN. AYE,
HUMBER. AYE. WELL HAVE HIY
WIENER. AYE, WILK. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. DELHI.
GROVE. JONES. WHEN NE OUR BOOK.
SEYARTO WHILK I 31 NÓ ZERO.
MOTION PASSES THE RESOLUTION
PASSES. NOW MEMBERS NOW IS THE
TIME TO RETURN TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. NOW IS THE TIME FOR
ADJOURN MEMORIES. AND WE'RE
GONNA ASK YOU TO TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE THE CONVERSATION OFF THE
FLOOR. FIRST UP IS CENTER ALLEN.
WELL THANK YOU MEMBERS. IT'S
WITH A HEAVY HEART THAT I RISE
TODAY TO ASK THAT WE ADJOURN IN
THE MEMORY OF ELENA LAYMAN OLE
WHO'S A TRUE PILLAR OF THE WEST
SIDE, POLISH AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
SHE WAS A MOTHER, A POLISH
IMMIGRANT AND A SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER WHO POURED HER LOVE FOR
HER CULTURE AND COMMUNITY INTO
HER RESTAURANT OR SAW ALINA WAS
BORN IN IN KRAKOW, BEAUTIFUL
CITY OF KRAKOW IN POLAND,
SOUTHERN POLAND, IN IN 1941. SHE
SPENT HER FORMATIVE YEARS WITH
HER WITH HER HOMELAND EMBROILED
IN WAR CONFLICT AND COMMUNISM.
REGARDLESS OF WHERE SHE FOUND
HERSELF THROUGHOUT HER LIFE.
THOSE EARLY YEARS FORGED WITHIN
HER AN IMMUTABLE LOVE FOR POLISH
CULTURE TRADITION. AND PERHAPS
MOST IMPORTANT CUISINE. 1968
WHEN ALINA WAS IN HER MID
TWENTIES, SHE MADE THE DECISION
TO EMIGRATE FROM HER HOME AND RE
ESTABLISH HERSELF IN BERKELEY.
AND HAVING ARRIVED IN THE UNITED
STATES, SHE FOUND HERSELF IN A
COMPLETELY UNFAMILIAR CULTURE AS
A NEWLY SINGLE MOTHER OF HER TWO
YOUNG CHILDREN. WITH ONLY
LIMITED ABILITY TO SPEAK THE
LANGUAGE. SHE CONNECTED WITH HER
NEW COMMUNITY THROUGH THE
LANGUAGE THAT SHE KNEW BEST
POLISH COOKING. ALINA LATER
EXPLAINED. WHENEVER I COOK
SOMETHING, PEOPLE WOULD SAY YOU
GOT TO OPEN A RESTAURANT. AND SO
I DID. IN 1972. JUST A FEW YEARS
AFTER ARRIVING HERE IN
CALIFORNIA, SHE TOOK THE ADVICE
OF HER NEW COUNTRYMEN AND OPENED
HER AUTHENTIC POLISH RESTAURANT.
UH, WHERE SHOW AND THEN A FEW
YEARS LATER, SHE REMARRIED AND
THE COUPLE RELOCATED TO MY
HOMETOWN OF SANTA MONICA
REESTABLISHED THE RESTAURANT ON
LINCOLN BOULEVARD, WHERE IT
STOOD FAITHFULLY SINCE 1979. HER
PROFOUND COMMUNITY LEGACY WAS
BORN THAT YEAR IN TWIN HALVES
ALONGSIDE RUNNING HER NEW
RESTAURANT, ELENA WAS RAISING
HER NEWBORN DAUGHTER. UH, MY
CHILDHOOD FRIEND NATASHA. UH,
FOR OVER 40 YEARS, ALINA
WELCOMED THE SANTA MONICA
COMMUNITY TO THE OLD WORLD OASIS
OF WHA TO EXPERIENCE AUTHENTIC
POLISH CULTURE AND COOKING
DESPITE BEING A SELF TRAINED
CHEF. HER PHENOMENAL COOKING
LITERALLY MADE HEADLINES WITH
HER BORSCHT RECIPE BEING
PUBLISHED IN THE L A TIMES THEY
DESCRIBE THE QUOTE, HOMEY LITTLE
RESTAURANT THAT HAS BEEN SERVING
AMAZINGLY POLISH FOOD IN SANTA
MONICA FOR DECADES, ADDING THAT
THOUGH IT MAY BE MOST FAMOUS FOR
ITS ROAST DUCK AND PIEROGI, THE
BORSCHT IS SIMPLY UNBELIEVABLE.
HER JOYFUL OUTLOOK EVEN CAPTURED
THE SILVER LINING OF HER
HOMELAND'S CULTURAL TURMOIL,
POINTING OUT IN AN INTERVIEW,
POLAND WAS IN A PART OF EUROPE
THAT WAS ALWAYS INVADED BY
SOMEONE. THE RESULT IS A LOT OF
FUSION IN POLISH DISHES. THE
PIEROGI IS LIKE RAVIOLIS FROM
OUR ITALIAN QUEEN THAT MARRIED
THE POLISH KING. BEYOND BEING A
SOURCE OF WORLD-CLASS POLISH
FOOD. THE RESTAURANT SERVED AS A
COMMUNITY HUB AND A GATHERING
PLACE THROUGHOUT THE EARLY DAYS
OF SANTA MONICA'S PROGRESSIVE
ERA. AND HAVING BEGUN HER TIME
IN CALIFORNIA, COOKING FOR HER
FRIENDS AND NEIGHBORS. SHE SAW
HER RESTAURANT THE SAME WAY IT
WAS IN WELCOMING SPACE, UH,
WHETHER CUSTOMERS WERE HER
FRIENDS, AND WHEN THEY WALKED
IN, THEY WOULD THEN YOU KNOW
WHETHER OR NOT THEY WERE FRIENDS
. THEY WOULD. THEY WOULD ALWAYS
LEAVE AS PART OF THE EXTENDED
FAMILY OF THE RESTAURANT. UH,
SHE WAS STEADFAST IN MAKING THE
RESTAURANT A SOURCE A FORCE FOR
GOOD BOTH PERSONALLY AND
SOCIETALLY. SHE HELD COUNTLESS
FUNDRAISERS, COMMUNITY GROUPS
OVER THE YEARS TO SUPPORT
IMPORTANT CAUSES AND SPARK
CONVERSATIONS. UH, AFTER DECADES
OF RUNNING THE CULTURAL
INSTITUTION. HER LEGACY CAME
FULL CIRCLE WHEN HE WHEN SHE
PASSED THE REINS TO HER
DAUGHTER, NATASHA IN 2015. AND
IN A POETIC PARALLEL TO HER
MOTHER'S JOURNEY, NATASHA HAD
JUST MOVED BACK FROM BERKELEY
HERSELF TO HER HOMETOWN, LEAVING
BEHIND HER CAREER IN SILICON
VALLEY AND EMBARKING ON THE NEW
CHALLENGE OF RUNNING A
RESTAURANT. UNLIKE HER MOTHER,
HOWEVER, NATASHA HAD ALINA'S
DECADES OF COMMITMENT TO HER
CRAFT AND OUR COMMUNITY TO SERVE
AS A GUIDE, AND SHE MARKED A NEW
CHAPTER FOR THE RESTAURANT BY
RENAMING IT. SOLIDARITY A NAME
BORROWED FROM POLAND'S FIRST
INDEPENDENT LABOR UNION THAT
GAVE RISE TO A COUNTRYWIDE
MOVEMENT THAT ULTIMATELY GAINED
TRUE INDEPENDENCE FROM THE
SOVIET. UH SOVIETS IN POLAND.
THE NAME IS HOMAGE TO ALINA
POLISH ROOTS, HER DEVOTION TO
HER HUSBAND AND HER FAMILY AND
HER UNFLINCHING SUPPORT FOR ALL
THOSE BOLD ENOUGH TO FIGHT FOR
PROGRESS IN THEIR COMMUNITY. AND
AS SHE CARRIES SOLIDARITY INTO
THE MODERN ERA, WITH CHANGES
LIKE DIGITAL SYSTEMS AND MODERN
DISHES AND A SPEAKEASY, NATASHA
HAS PRESERVED HER MOTHER'S LIFE
WORK FOR THE NEXT GENERATION TO
ENJOY. AND I'LL JUST SAY IT'S
GOT A SPECIAL PLACE IN MY HEART
IS WHERE WE HAD OUR, UH UH,
VICTORY PARTIES WHEN I FIRST WAS
RUNNING FOR THIS SEAT BOTH IN
THE PRIMARY AND THE GENERAL, SO
I ALWAYS FEEL AS THOUGH THE
PLACE HAS A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
MAGIC FOR ME, AND I'VE HAD A
BIRTHDAY PARTY THERE. IT'S A
WONDERFUL PLACE, AND I'D LOVE TO
TAKE YOU GUYS THERE IF YOU COME
OUT TO SANTA MONICA AT SOME
POINT IN ADDITION TO ITS ONGOING
STEWARDSHIP OF POLISH TRADITION,
ALINA'S RESTAURANT CONTINUES TO
OFFER A HOME TO ALL THOSE WHO
CARE ENOUGH ABOUT OUR COMMUNITY
TO BELIEVE IN ITS BETTERMENT
DESPITE BARELY SPEAKING ENGLISH
WHEN SHE ARRIVED, SHE WAS
COMMITTED TO LEARNING AND
DEVELOPING PERSONALLY, SO MUCH
SO THAT IN HER LATER YEARS SHE
NOT ONLY MASTERED THREE
LANGUAGES, BUT SHE NEVER MET A
NEW YORK TIMES CROSSWORD PUZZLE
SHE COULDN'T SOLVE, EVEN EVEN
SUNDAYS. SO HER MEMORY LIVES ON,
UH, IN ALL THOSE WHO LOVED HER,
BUT ALSO IN THE VALUES AND THE
IDEAS IN THIS WONDERFUL PLACE
THAT SHE LAID GAVE TO ALL OF US
IN ON THE WEST SIDE. SHE
SURVIVED BY HER HUSBAND, PAUL,
HER THREE DAUGHTERS, HER FOUR
GRANDCHILDREN, ALONG WITH THE
EXTENDED MARAWA FAMILY. UH,
SHE'S A BRILLIANT LOVING
CALIFORNIAN. HER POLISH SPIRIT
WILL CONTINUE TO WARM HEARTS AND
WELCOME HEARTS FROM THE CORNER
OF LINCOLN IN SANTA MONICA
BOULEVARD. I ASK THAT YOU
ADJOURN IN ALINA'S MEMORY TODAY.
THANK YOU. WE EXTEND OUR DEEPEST
SENATE. CONDOLENCES AND WE ASK
THAT YOU BRING THE NAME FORWARD
SO SHE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED. NEXT UP IS SENATOR
WEINER. I THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT. UH, COLLEAGUES. UH,
IT'S WITH GREAT SADNESS. UM THAT
I RISE TO ASK THAT THE SENATE
ADJOURN. IN MEMORY OF AN ENTIRE
FAMILY, AN ENTIRE SAN FRANCISCO
FAMILY. UH, THAT WAS KILLED WHEN
A CAR CRASHED INTO THEM. A
FAMILY THAT WAS WIPED OUT AND
ONE FELL SWOOP. THAT WAS TAKEN.
FAR TOO SOON. AND UH, JUST A
DISASTER THAT HAS SHAKEN THE
ENTIRE SAN FRANCISCO COMMUNITY.
UM ON MARCH 16TH, A SATURDAY UH
DIEGO CARDOSO DE OLIVEIRA,
MATILDE MONCADA RAMOS PINTO. UH,
WHO ARE THE LOVING PARENTS OF
ONE YEAR OLD JOAQUIN AND HIS
THREE MONTH OLD BROTHER, UH, KO.
THE FOUR OF THEM WERE WAITING AT
A BUS STOP IN SAN FRANCISCO. AND
A CAR CRASH INTO THEM, AND ALL
FOUR DIED. THEIR FAMILY
DESCRIBES THEM AS WARM AND
LOVING PARENTS WHO HAD A DEEP
LOVE FOR THEIR BEAUTIFUL
CHILDREN AND ENJOY NOTHING MORE
THAN SPENDING TIME WITH THEIR
TWO LITTLE BOYS. THEY WERE ALSO
WHAT ONE WOULD CALL REAL LIFE
ENHANCERS, THE KIND OF PEOPLE
THAT EVERYONE LOVED TO BE AROUND
HAPPY, FUNNY KIND AND ALWAYS
EAGER TO MAKE THE BEST OF WHAT
LIFE HAD TO OFFER THEM. DIEGO
AND MATILDA LIVED IN SAN
FRANCISCO'S MISSION DISTRICT.
UH, DIEGO WAS A BRAZILIAN
CITIZEN WHO WORKED AS A CREATIVE
DIRECTOR AT APPLE. UH, MATILDA
WORKED AS A PRODUCER WITH R S¼ A
FILMS. ON THE DAY OF THE CRASH.
UH DIEGO AND MATILDA WERE
CELEBRATING THEIR WEDDING
ANNIVERSARY. UM AND AS THE
AMAZING PARENTS THAT THEY WERE,
THEY CELEBRATED THEIR WEDDING
ANNIVERSARY BY, UH OR THE PLAN
WAS TO TAKE THEIR TWO CHILDREN
TO THE ZOO TO SAN FRANCISCO ZOO.
HAVING RECENTLY SOLD THEIR CAR.
UH THEY WERE TAKING THE BUS TO
THE ZOO WAITING FOR THE BUS. AND
THEY WERE WAITING AT A BUS STOP
IN WEST PORTAL. UH, AND THE CAR
CRASHED INTO THEM. RED DIED THAT
DAY. UH ONE OF THE CHILDREN DIED
SEVERAL DAYS LATER. UH, AFTER A
FIGHT FOR HIS LIFE AT THE
HOSPITAL AT SAN FRANCISCO
GENERAL. UM I CANNOT OVERSTATE
THE LEVEL OF GRIEF IN OUR
COMMUNITY. FOR THIS TO HAPPEN.
FOR THIS ENTIRE FAMILY TO BE
WAITING AT THE BUS STOP ONE
MOMENT. AND GONE THE NEXT IT'S
JUST DEVASTATING. COLLEAGUES UH,
WE ALL KNOW IN OUR OWN
COMMUNITIES THAT FAR TOO MANY
CALIFORNIANS, UM, ARE DYING
EVERY DAY. BECAUSE OF TRAFFIC
VIOLENCE ON OUR ROADS. WE'VE
SEEN A RISE IN TRAFFIC DEATHS.
IN RECENT YEARS MORE THAN 4000.
CALIFORNIANS DIE ON OUR ROADS
EVERY YEAR. THAT'S 11 EVERY
SINGLE DAY. THESE ARE COMPLETELY
PREVENTABLE DEATHS. IT'S NOT
INEVITABLE. IT'S A POLICY
CHOICE. THAT CALIFORNIA IS
TOLERATING THIS LEVEL OF DEATH
ON OUR ROADS. IT DOESN'T HAVE TO
BE THIS WAY. IN THE TESTAMENT TO
THE CHARACTER OF THIS FAMILY.
UH, THE BABY. UH KOREA, WHO
SURVIVED FOR SEVERAL DAYS BEFORE
DYING. UM IT WAS ANNOUNCED THAT
THE FAMILY'S RELATIVES HAD
DONATED HIS ORGANS TO SAVE THE
LIVES OF OTHER CHILDREN. I WANT
TO THANK THE FAMILY FOR TAKING
THIS TRAGEDY AND HOPEFULLY OTHER
CHILDREN WILL SURVIVE AS A
RESULT OF THIS DISASTER. UH,
PLEASE JOIN ME IN ADJOURNING
TODAY. IN MEMORY OF DIEGO,
MATILDA, JOAQUIN AND Kò. MAY YOU
REST IN PEACE. THANK YOU ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE WEEKS EXTEND OUR MOST
SINCERE CONDOLENCES TO THE LOST
AND ASK THAT YOU BRING THE NAME
FORWARD SO THE ENTIRE FAMILY CAN
BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED. NEXT
UP IS SENATOR DALLY. THANK YOU,
MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS. IT'S WITH
A HEAVY HEART THAT I RISE TODAY
TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF ONE
OF OUR OWN. UH, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BRIAN NANDI. JUST TO START OUT
WITH. I'D LIKE TO SAY THAT WHEN
I CAME TO THE ASSEMBLY, UH, I
WAS THE FOURTH BRIAN IN OUR
CAUCUS AND WE HAD OUR OWN CAUCUS
. THE BRIAN CAUCUS. UH, SENATOR
JONES MYSELF. BRIAN IS SANDY
AND, UH, SIM. UH, SENATOR, UH,
BRIAN MAINS SHINE. BRIAN AND
SANDY, DEDICATED PUBLIC SERVANT
AND FORMER ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHO
PASSED AWAY AT THE AGE OF 60.
BRIAN'S CONTRIBUTION TO HIS
COMMUNITY AND HIS COMMITMENT TO
PUBLIC SERVICE. WILL WE BE
RENDERED AND CHERISHED? BRIAN
CAME FROM A POLITICAL FAMILY
FOLLOWING IN THE FOOTSTEPS OF
HIS FATHER, BRUCE, KENNETH
NANDI. WHO SERVED AS A
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. BRIAN'S OWN POLITICAL
CAREER. BEGAN AS A CHIEF OF
STAFF FOR SUNNY AND MARY BONO
DURING THEIR TERMS IN CONGRESS.
HE LATER SERVED IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY FROM
2008 TO 2014, REPRESENTING THE
CLA COACHELLA VALLEY. BRIAN'S
LEADERSHIP AND DEDICATION TO HIS
CONSTITUENTS WAS A IT WAS
EVIDENT THROUGHOUT HIS CAREER.
HE WAS KNOWN FOR HIS ABILITY TO
UNDERSTAND THE NUANCES OF THE
LEGISLATIVE WORK, AND HIS
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS IS PRAGMATIC
, ÁP APPROACH AND WILLINGNESS TO
WORK ACROSS PARTY LINES MADE HIM
A RESPECTED FIGURE IN THE
POLITICAL ARENA. BEYOND HIS
POLITICAL ACHIEVEMENTS. BRIAN
AND SANDY WAS DEVOTED A DEVOTED
FAMILY MAN. HE LEAVES BEHIND HIS
WIFE, GINA. HIS CHILDREN AND
STEPCHILDREN. AND OUR THOUGHTS
AND PRAYERS GO OUT TO HIS FAMILY
DURING THIS DIFFICULT TIME.
BRIAN'S PASSING IS A LOSS NOT
ONLY FOR HIS FAMILY BUT ALSO FOR
THE COMMUNITY HE SERVED. HIS
IMPACT WILL BE REMEMBERED BY
THOSE WHO HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
WORKING WITH HIM AND WITNESSING
HIS DEDICATION TO PUBLIC
SERVICE. AS WE ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF BRIAN AND STANDING,
LET US HONOR HIS LEGACY. BY
CONTINUING TO WORK TOWARDS THE
BETTER MEN OF OUR COMMUNITIES
AND THE PURSUIT OF GOOD
GOVERNANCE. MAY HIS MEMORY
INSPIRE US TO STRIVE FOR
BIPARTISANSHIP, UNDERSTANDING
AND EFFECTIVE LEADERSHIP MEMBERS
. UM THERE WILL BE A RECEPTION
IN ROOM UH, 317 FOLLOWING THE
ADJOURNMENT OF THE SENATE. UH I
JUST ASKED THAT WE ADJOURN IN
THE MEMORY OF OUR OWN COLLEAGUE.
ONE OF THE BRIAN CAUCUSES. UM
MEMBERS, UH, MEMBERS. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR ATTENTION. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. SENATOR BRADFORD,
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT AND I, TOO WANT
TO RISE AND ADD MY VOICE. FIRST
OF THANKS TO BRIAN SANDY, UH,
BRIAN AND B WHAT IT MEANT TO BE
A STATESMAN. HE BOUGHT EMBODIED
WHAT IT MEANT TO BE A TRUE
PUBLIC SERVANT AND AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BEAVER STATED, HE
WORKED ACROSS PARTY LINES ON ALL
ISSUES, AND EVEN WHEN HE WAS
VOTING AGAINST YOUR BILL, HE DID
IT WITH THAT KOOL AID SMILE ALL
THE TIME. AND I AM HONORED TO
CALL HIM A FRIEND. CALL HIM A
COLLEAGUE AND I WAS JUST BLOWN
AWAY WHEN I HEARD ABOUT HIS
PASSING BECAUSE BRIAN AND I,
ALONG WITH OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
OAKLAND, WE ARE JUST CELEBRATED
OUR CLASS REUNION JUST AND
NOVEMBER IN PALM SPRINGS, AND
EVEN THOUGH IT WAS HOSTED AND
COORDINATE BY OUR FORMER SPEAKER
, JOHN PEREZ, BRIAN PRETTY MUCH
COORDINATE EVERYTHING THAT
HAPPENED DOWN IN THE VALLEY THAT
DAY FROM THE TRAM RIDE TO THE
TOP OF THE MOUNT SAN CENTER TO
THE DINNER TO JUST AMAZING TIME
WE HAD IN TOWN THAT NIGHT, AND
AS USUAL, HE HAD TO SMILE. HE
GAVE ME A HUG. AND HE SAYS,
BRADFORD, WHEN ARE YOU GONNA
CALL ME ABOUT GOLF? BECAUSE HE
KNEW MY PASSION FOR GOLF, AND HE
ALWAYS SAID, WE ALWAYS HAVE A
GOLF COURSE AVAILABLE AND IT WAS
WITH BRIAN THAT I FIRST PLAYED
BIG HORN DOWN IN THE DESERT BE
BECAUSE OF HIS ARRANGEMENT OF
THAT TEE TIME AND JUST FAST
FORWARD. THREE WEEKS LATER, WE
WERE IN LAS VEGAS AT AN ENERGY
CONFERENCE AND I WAS ON A PANEL
AND I LOOKED BACK IN THE BACK OF
THE ROOM, AND THERE WAS BRIAN IN
THE BACK OF THE ROOM WITH A BIG
SMILE ON HIS FACE, AND THAT'S
WHAT I WILL ALWAYS REMEMBER AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO ALWAYS LOOKED FOR
COMPROMISE. WANTED TO YOU KNOW,
FIND A WAY TO MAKE A WAY AND
SOMEONE WHO ALWAYS I DON'T CARE
WHAT THE CONVERSATION WAS ABOUT,
ALWAYS CENTERED AROUND HIS
FAMILY, AND BRIAN NEVER MISSED
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TALK ABOUT
HIS WIFE AND TALK ABOUT HIS KIDS
. AND THAT'S OUR LAST
CONVERSATION THAT WE HAD IN LAS
VEGAS, AND I'M GONNA TRULY MISS
HIM. AND, UM I MEAN, HE WAS A
SPECIAL GUY, AND FOR THOSE OF US
WHO SERVED WITH HIM, WE KNOW
WHAT HE MEANT. BUT HE WILL
NEVER, EVER BE FORGOTTEN. HE'LL
ALWAYS BE IN OUR HEART AND I ASK
THAT WE ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
BRIAN ASANTI. SAID ANILLO.
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. I, UH RISE IN
HONOR OF BRIAN ALSO I WAS
CERTAINLY SADDENED BUT
ABSOLUTELY SHOCKED BY HIS DEATH.
I HADN'T SEEN HIM FOR A FEW
YEARS. HE AND I SERVED TOGETHER
IN THE ASSEMBLY. MY LAST, UH,
TWO YEARS. UM AND HE WAS JUST
TOO YOUNG. TO PASS AWAY. UH HE
HAS BEEN DESCRIBED WELL, UM,
ALREADY IN THE PREVIOUS REMARKS
AND I, I CAN'T ADD TOO MUCH TO
THAT, EXCEPT I WOULD SAY THAT
PICTURE OF HIM DOES CAPTURE HIS
SMILE AND HIS FRIENDLINESS. UM
HE WAS A ROCK SOLID CONSERVATIVE
, BUT A GUY THAT EVERYBODY LIKED
AND GOT ALONG WITH. AND, UH, A
TRUE SERMON, A TRUE
COLLABORATOR. AND UH, AS I LOOK
BACK ON THE MANY PHASES OF MY
LIFE. THE DIFFERENT EXPERIENCES
I'VE HAD. I WALK AWAY FROM EACH
ONE. VALUING THE RELATIONSHIPS.
THAT I MAKE. RELATIONSHIPS I
WOULD NOT HAVE OTHERWISE HAD,
AND BRIAN SANDY WAS ONE OF THOSE
AND, UH, I AM JUST SO SADDENED
THAT THAT RELATIONSHIP IS NÓ
LONGER WITH US. SENATOR SKINNER.
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, UH, I
ALSO SERVED WITH, UM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IN AS NODE. WE GOT
ELECTED THE SAME YEAR, SO WE
STARTED AND SPENT, UH, SIX YEARS
IN THE ASSEMBLY TOGETHER. HE WAS
TOO YOUNG. I ECHOED THOSE
COMMENTS. HE SHOULD NOT. IT'S
YOU SHOULD NOT, UH, BE TAKEN AT
THAT AGE AND UNEXPECTEDLY AS HE
WAS BRIAN AS A ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
WE SERVED IN THE TIME WHEN
REQUIRED A TWO THIRDS VOTE TO
PASS A BUDGET. AND YOU THINK
BUDGETS ARE HARD NOW. YOU DON'T
KNOW ANYTHING THAT'S HARD UNTIL
YOU HAVE THE SITUATION WHERE IT
REQUIRES A TWO THIRDS VOTE. AND
THE NEGOTIATIONS THAT GO ON FOR
MONTHS, ACTUALLY. BUT BRIAN WAS
WILLING TO ROLL UP HIS SLEEVES
AND NEGOTIATE. HE WAS NOT JUST A
SAY NÓ. AND WE REACHED AGREEMENT
ON BUDGETS VERY COMMONLY BECAUSE
OF BRIAN. NOT ONLY BUT A LOT.
SIGNIFICANTLY. HE WAS A TEAM
PLAYER. HE UNDERSTOOD THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS A TEAM SPORT,
EVEN IF WE'RE DIFFERENT PARTIES.
IT IS STILL ANY OF US TO SUCCEED
REQUIRES THE SUPPORT OF OUR
COLLEAGUES. WE MUST HAVE VOTES
FROM OUR COLLEAGUES. WE MUST
NEGOTIATE. WE MUST GET OUR
THINGS OUT OF COMMITTEES WITH
OUR COLLEAGUES. HE UNDERSTOOD
THAT. AND HE WAS A REAL TEAM
PLAYER. HE WILL BE SO MISSED AND
II. I FEEL BEREFT THAT HE WAS
TAKEN FROM US THIS EARLY.
SENATOR ROTH. YOU RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU. UM, MADAM PRESIDENT?
I OF COURSE. KNEW BRIAN. WHEN HE
WAS UP HERE. WE SERVED TOGETHER.
HE WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY. I WAS IN
THE SENATE, HE REPRESENTED A
PORTION OF RIVERSIDE COUNTY,
EASTERN RIVERSIDE COUNTY. UH BUT
I KNEW BRIAN BEFORE THAT,
ACTUALLY, UM, I KNEW HIM WHEN HE
WORKED FOR SONNY BONO AND MARY
BONO WHEN, UH, THEY WERE
CONGRESSIONAL REPRESENTATIVES
FROM OUR PART OF THE WORLD. HIS
BROTHER BARRY. I ALSO KNEW HIS
BROTHER WAS CHIEF OF STAFF TO
FORMER ASSEMBLY MEMBER FORMER
STATE SENATOR FORMER RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SUPERVISOR JOHN BENOIT.
AND WHEN HIS BROTHER BARRY,
DIED. SUDDENLY UNEXPECTEDLY AT A
VERY YOUNG AGE. BRIAN AND HIS
WIFE, GINA TOOK OVER AS AS THE
LEADERS. OF THAT FAMILY. THE
LAST TIME I SAW BRIAN FRANKLY,
HE WAS, OF COURSE NOT IN THE
ASSEMBLY. HE WAS WORKING IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY. HE WAS
ACTUALLY PASSING OUT TURKEYS AT
A TURKEY GIVEAWAY ON
THANKSGIVING. THIS LAST
THANKSGIVING, PASSING OUT
TURKEYS TO THOSE WHO NEEDED HELP
, AND WE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
TALK AND GET TOGETHER AGAIN. HE
WAS VERY CONCERNED ABOUT MY
EXTRACURRICULAR ACTIVITY THIS
YEAR, VERY INTERESTED IN HOW
THAT WAS TURNING OUT, AND WE HAD
A WE HAD A VERY VERY GOOD
CONVERSATION. BUT I'M I'M JUST I
WAS TAKEN AT THE TIME. AND I
RECALL IT NOW, BRIAN, THE DANDY,
HELPING THOSE WHO NEED HELP THE
MOST. UM HE WAS KIND. HE WAS
HELPFUL. HE WAS HONEST. HE WAS
STRAIGHTFORWARD. HE WAS ALL OF
THOSE THINGS IN MUCH, MUCH MORE,
UH, WE'RE BETTER OFF. BUT THE
FACT THAT HE WAS WITH US AND WE
WILL MISS HIM A LOT. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. OUR DEEP AND
SINCERE CONDOLENCES TO THE
FAMILY UP IN THE GALLERY. SIN
DOY. IF YOU COULD PLEASE COME
BRING THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS NAME
FORWARD. THAT WE MAY PROPERLY
MEMORIZE HIM. NOW MOVING ON TO A
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS. SENATOR
ALVARADO HILL. YOU'RE RECOGNIZED
. THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT,
UM, THE COMMITTEE FOR HUMAN
SERVICES WILL BE MEETING UPON
ADJOURNMENT AT THREE O'CLOCK IN
ROOM 2200. THANK YOU, SENATOR.
IF THERE'S NÓ OTHER BUSINESS,
SENATOR MCGUIRE THE DEATH
SENATOR DOLLY FOR WHAT PURPOSE?
YOU I JUST WANTED TO ADD THAT,
UH, BRIAN'S, UH, CHIEF OF STAFF
AND MEMBERS WERE IN THE IN THE
GALLERY, AND I JUST WANTED TO
RECOGNIZE THEM AS WELL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR. SENATOR
W FOR WHAT PURPOSE? YOU RISE.
CAN I STILL MOVE AN ITEM TO AN
ACTIVE FILE? WE'RE MOVING BACK
TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. BUT
WHEN YOU'RE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT, PLEASE
MOVE ITEM S¼ èC R 100 FROM THE
ENACTED FILE. THE DEATHS WERE
NOT THANK YOU. SENATOR OF
PURPOSE. RICE SENATOR GS
CONDITION OF THE FILE. MEMBERS
WERE GOING TO TAKE A QUICK FIVE
MINUTE BREAK LESS THAN FIVE
MINUTES FIVE SECONDS.
COLLEAGUES A COUPLE MORE MINUTES
HERE, WE'RE GONNA BE MOVING TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR AND
RECOGNIZING SENATOR GLAZER.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT MANY
MEMBERS ARE VERY EXCITED TO HEAR
THE NEWS THAT, UH, OUR NEXT
SESSION THAT'S SCHEDULED FOR
THURSDAY THAT WE'RE GONNA WE'RE
GONNA HAVE IT OUT ON THE
CAPITOL. UH, LINE. UH, CLOSER TO
THE PEOPLE UNDER THE BEAUTY THAT
WE HAVE HERE IN OUR CAPITOL PARK
, AND SO I JUST WANTED TO SAY
HOW APPRECIATIVE I AM FOR THE
LEADERSHIP AND THEIR WILLINGNESS
TO BRING US OUT OF OUR CHAMBER.
UH, TO BE CLOSER TO THE PEOPLE
THIS COMING THURSDAY. SO WITH
THAT, THANK YOU. SEEN AS THERE
IS OFFICIALLY NÓ FURTHER
BUSINESS, SENATOR MAGUIRE THE
DUST IS CLEAR. THANK YOU SO MUCH
, MADAM PRESIDENT. YES UH, FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS THAT, UH, LAST
NAME STARTS WITH G ENDS WITH R.
THERE WILL BE SESSION OUT OF THE
LAWN. SO UM, BUT, UH, MEMBERS,
UH, WE WANT TO SAY, UH, WELCOME
YOU BACK, UH, TO, UH, THE
REMAINDER OF THE YEAR KNOW THAT
EVERYONE HAD A PRODUCTIVE TIME
IN THEIR DISTRICTS WORKING IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES. WE HAVE HIT
OUR BUSY SEASON. OFFICIALLY WE
HAVE COMMITTEES GOING. BUDGET IS
MOVING, UH, AND WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR HARD
WORK, AND IT'S GOOD TO SEE
EVERYONE BACK. OUR NEXT FLOOR
SESSION IS GONNA BE THIS
THURSDAY. WITH THE EXCEPTION OF
GNR, UH, HERE IN THE CHAMBERS
THURSDAY, APRIL 4TH AT 9 A.M.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. IT'S
OUR VERSION OF MARCH MADNESS.
THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL 3:30 P.M. AT WHICH TIME
THE GERMAN MOTION WILL BE MADE.
WE WILL RECONVENE THURSDAY AT 9
A.M.